John Cena's Mandarin chinese is
an example of people who learn
a language for a certain purpose
and pull it off successfully.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here, um, today,
a bit of an unusual subject, maybe,
uh, someone asked me how well does
John Cena speak Mandarin Chinese.
So the title is John Cena speaking
Mandarin Chinese, but I want to
really talk about the importance of
communicating when we learn a language
and then the relative lack of importance
of perfect pronunciation or even other
imperfections in our use of a language
that we learn in order to communicate.
So someone asked me, and by the way, if
you enjoy these videos, please subscribe,
click on the bell for notification.
And if you're following me
on a podcast service, please
leave a comment or a review.
So a friend said, what do you
think of John Cena's Chinese?
To be honest, I don't, didn't know
who John Cena was CENA turns out
he's some kind of a pro wrestler.
Uh, I'm not a big fan of professional
wrestling, uh, but, uh, whatever
he is a well-known personality.
So I looked him up.
So what do I think?
His Chinese is not what
you would call phenomenal.
His pronunciation is not very Chinese.
However, It's very pleasing.
He communicates.
You have the feeling that he
wants to communicate, that he
likes the Chinese language.
He likes communicating
with his Chinese fans.
Uh, there's something very positive.
Now, I'm not a native speaker of
Chinese so I can't, I can't tell
you how a Chinese person reacts.
Maybe some of you who are Chinese can
tell me your reaction to his Chinese.
But to me, it comes
across as quite positive.
Um, And, uh, so I, I thought of
all these people that I know who
communicate very effectively in a
language that they speak imperfectly.
Uh, we can start with, uh, former
Canadian prime minister, Jean
Chrétien, and he speaks with a
pronounced the French Canadian accent.
And even his usage is not always
a hundred percent yet he was very
effective, so effective communicating
in English that he was prime minister
of Canada for I think 10 years.
And was very popular.
Uh, you know, I it's possible just
as you know, John Cena uses his
Chinese it's part of his shtick of
connecting with his Chinese fans.
I think to some extent, or some people
suspected that Jean Chrétien affected
his, you know, Quebecois accent on his
English, because it was part of his
persona and he was a very successful uh,
politician, but they both communicate.
Um, if you watch, uh, Mark Zuckerberg
speak Chinese, my impression
is that he may in fact speak
Chinese better than John Cena.
I don't know.
But, uh, he's not tremendous either,
but you have the impression that
he isn't really communicating
so much as he's performing.
Uh, his attitude is, uh,
speaking to his Chinese audience
in Beijing "oh, look at me.
I can speak Chinese.
Uh, I'm very clever.
Aren't I?"
Kind of thing.
Uh, so that the audience is kind
of a prop, so at least that's the
impression that's created with me.
It may not be fair, but you know,
I think the important thing in
communicating is that genuine
desire to communicate, to connect.
And, uh, as I've said, many times,
I, you know, I remember I had a Swiss
banker who spoke English so well, but
had a pronounced Swiss accent, uh, all
the different people that I've, you
know, done business with who spoke, but
who communicated and they didn't for a
minute, worry about their pronunciation
or the odd little error in their language.
And so that's where, you know, many of
us, as we're learning a language, of
course, we want to continue to improve,
but whatever our level, whatever your
level, whatever you are, you have
to measure what you have achieved
against what your objectives are.
So if your objective let's say in
learning Japanese is to absolutely
master the pronunciation to sound
like someone on national radio in
Japan, and you're going to work on
your pitch accent and that's fine.
I'm not critical of that.
But to suggest that everyone
learning Japanese should put the
same amount of effort into mastering
pitch accent is to my mind silly.
I have never, I was blithely for all the
time I lived in Japan I never even knew
such a thing as pitch accent existed.
I'm sure that in trying to imitate
Japanese as spoken by native speakers
and of course falling short, but
nevertheless, using that as a model
I would not necessarily imitate
some aspects of pitch accent.
And similarly in speaking Persian,
which I'm told is a language that has
pitch accent, if I tried to imitate
the way the native speakers speak, to
some extent, I will imitate that pitch
accent, but I'm not going to study
it with the intention of aceing it.
Uh, it's just part of my
acquisition of the language.
And, uh, there will be imperfections,
uh, as I've said before there, I don't
know what we have a Russian person that
works with us and, uh, his, his articles
use of the article is very haphazard.
It doesn't prevent him from being a very
comfortable communicator in English.
Um, you know, people make
mistakes in gender in French.
I did my video, uh, about
the difficulties of French.
Uh, it's, it's important to be
aware of some of these difficulties
and work on some of them.
I mean, we can work on,
on getting the 'r' right.
But if we can't quite do the guttural
'r' in French a hundred percent like the
French, it doesn't prevent communication.
Uh, I think it's worth working
on the 'eu' sound, the famous...
go 'ooo' and then  try to say 'e'
and you'll get 'eu' it's worth
working on it, but if you don't get
it, it's not the end of the world.
Uh, similarly with the,
uh, the nasal sounds.
I think they are worth working on,
noticing them, trying to do as well as
you can with the nasal sounds because
it will also help your comprehension,
but when you speak and when you are
genuinely communicating, communicating
with someone, just communicate.
So if I get back to John Cena and his
Mandarin Chinese, he does communicate.
I don't know, I haven't seen him
discuss philosophy in Chinese, but
those things that he does talk about he
communicates effectively, uh, I don't
know, uh, how many tones he gets right.
I think it's pretty haphazard,
but he's happy doing it.
And I think people listening to him
again, I can't speak for Chinese
people, but I have the impression that
Chinese people are happy to see him
speaking Chinese to the extent that
he speaks it and he is communicating.
So, uh, I guess where I come to in all of
this is John Cena's Mandarin chinese is
an example of people who learn a language
for a certain purpose and pull it off
successfully and obviously enjoy it.
And really that's what language
learning is all about enjoyment and of
course, communication or communicating
with people, connecting with people.
So there you have it, a bit of um,
you know, digression perhaps from
the title, but just talking about the
importance of communicating without
worrying too much about perfection.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.